and I'm gonna divide you guys up we put
yeah we put the lights on because I want
to try and like make sure you feel
responsible for your suggestion if the
lights are off it's just some gross guy
in the corner just going back seing your
[ __ ] and no one wants that so there's
a gentleman at the back laughing of that
heartily like that is exactly what I was
gonna do
I see bro so let's come to the back
section first if you are in that kind of
like Boothby section what would you like
there's a hand over there yeah what
would you like a rap about oh ok
Carswell let's be more specific cars are
very general topics like you know like a
specific type of car or something to do
with cars like making sure you check
your oil or something a Dodge Dart let
me just check that's a tiny [ __ ] car
right I would really really funny if the
person who said their English is like oh
he now insulted my awful car as well
okay so the Dodge Dart which is a tiny
bad car why does that come to mind in
particular that's okay that's a valid
reason what Oh DeLorean well okay Dodge
Dart vs. DeLorean thank you you made the
suggestion better let's come to you guys
this is kind of a sparsely attended area
let's like why is everyone packed over
there and no one over here what yeah
yummy you guys look really unhappy about
it okay so what what do you guys want to
wrap that on this side Klingons and what
do they what you've got a hand up over
there what you want a space-traveling
mal practicing urologist that is better
than a Klingon I'm afraid you know I
know we could combine them but to be
honest I don't want to corrupt what is
it an exceptional suggestion that you've
clearly been thinking about for quite a
while okay a space traveling mal
practicing neurologist are you familiar
with Kool Keith and his character doctor
octagon yeah really
are you just saying that cuz I've said
that yeah he is yes said that cool keith
is a rapper who is it has a character of
a space dine ecologist so I was
wondering if that was similar to that
but
she said you said urology cause she's in
you've been outed as a urologist I'm
afraid at least you didn't say you were
space-traveling all-male practicing
that's okay so Dodge Dart vs. DeLorean a
space traveling mal practicing
neurologist let's come to kind of the
middle of the room you guys are a big
group let's come up with something great
white people that's a great suggestion
let's um let's expand that thing late
let's pick focus on a specific thing
white people do like I don't know like
kissing their dogs or something someone
else can help out on this as well I
doesn't have to all from the same person
wait wait oh oh wait so you said
drinking something but then you said the
the college cheating scandal is that
right the oh the Astrotech wait was that
just white people I mean I imagine that
the coach and the owner of the franchise
were why okay white people and how they
love to cheat especially in baseball you
guys are making these suggestions really
hard Dodge Dart vs. DeLorean white
people and how they love to cheat the
space traveling malpractice guys over
here what you want to hear a rack them
airport security and sex toys getting a
sex toy through airport security I like
it week week that was a very cool moment
we did it when women work together we
can be do anything okay and let's get
one final suggestion and this this
should be really good because so far
these are being at such a high bar so I
don't mean to let us down it doesn't
come from anywhere you said you said
anime you said sasquatch and what did
you say sequence okay cool
[Music]
I'm gonna say Sasquatch Sasquatch with
sequence I like that that sounds more
fun I've done I've done a wrap up
Bigfoot specifically recently so I kind
of want to make it more difficult like
that okay cool and Sasquatch with
sequins getting a sex toy through
airport security a Dodge Dart vs. Lorien
and mal practicing space traveling
urologist and the the Houston Astros
cheating scandal but focusing on white
people okay guys
usually I make big promises about this
I'm like this is going to be the best
thing you've ever seen and I am doubting
myself right now but don't worry it's
gonna be good it's gonna be better than
you're expecting a privately educated
middle-class white British boy to be
that's what I promise with this I am
very excited yeah and even though they
didn't get kicked out MLB baseball sort
of [ __ ] why cuz they're going to bleats
and then we know white people they love
in the cheatin they say we got privilege
but it's still tough man so they cheat
like Felicity Huffman in the college's
you should educate kids where the
knowledge is you don't need to pay
people to fake exams if you're in the
baseball then the offseason just learn
how to predict the pitch to don't be a
damn cheat in son of a [ __ ] who's white
I was mistaken asteroids were Caucasian
who only
or should not let me try and race you
within the Porsche car why I'm always
being you in the core of mile cuz you
drive a Dodge Dart
it's a car for a child about this big
made by George when it comes to
mechanics it's a real hodgepodge of the
engine [ __ ] and the horse powers weak
it's got no grip you could drive it in
your sleep and if you crashed it would
amass your bones wouldn't shower let me
talk about a scientist a man huh from
back to the future
I'm not boring again talking about the
three movies with the DeLorean the first
one a real wild guy Soulfly saying stop
Marty McFly was my name's Christopher
brown only thirty were ever sold if you
buy it with the flux capacitor that's
like gold
you hold the nerves buy it and know if
they try and keep it secret in the
carriage like a sex toy in your baggage
when you carry your teeth if this battle
ends it's going through the TSA line I
know your friends his weed and drugs and
other stuff great you have Barbies
purple dildos that you want to stop
inside somewhere in the cavity TSA agent
saying understand the gravity you can't
steal this really trying to try it
you've got a disinfectant removal
coronavirus samples
I know it's science I try and fare down
there between my thighs and all the
people on their x-ray machine raise the
eyebrows when they say wow this one is
green you can't tell the color from the
UV rays I take this pill though it goes
on for days and if you put it inside
this a heck of a risk you might get
infected
Dede urologist
he's not in your face he's up there with
he's going through space and when you
get a vibrator that's a buzz so strong
Buzz Aldrin and Neil Armstrong could
meet this guy cuz up in the universe a
urologist who says that make occurs pull
your pants down on the couch bend over
quickly take your posture don't slouch
he inserts a little finger into my
urethra I wish there was lubrication
making me easier sadly he goes in dry
it's horrible it really makes me wanna
cry my would be easy shimmers in the
light so he comes out at night creeping
up behind the Taurus and giving them a
fright and they run away jug like huh
scrub scotch from the massive secret
creature call this a sport there you go
thank you very much for watching please
watch more with playlists and subscribe
like comment all those things shouting
bye
[Applause]